[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a nice instrument has the purity and the
clarity of the heavenly realm it's not
of the earth in the way that a wooden
instrument would be there's so much
potential in ice as an acoustic material
[Music]
my name is Tim Lynn Hart and I am the
founder of ice music ice music is the
music that we make on this Orchestra of
ice instruments the idea first came to
me about 21 years ago I was an ice
sculptor for many years decided one of
my sculptures I'd like to build a giant
violin and I had a friend who was
building guitars and he just asked the
question
gee I wonder how that one's gonna sound
and that question has swallowed much of
the rest of my life the instruments are
made of white ice which is a mixture of
snow and water it's filled with as
snowflakes and air bubbles and they're
all kind of different things going on to
make a single instrument of violin or
viola here the ice part takes about five
or six days I can probably build the
whole Orchestra here in about seven or
eight weeks we have violins violas
cellos bass guitars mandolins banjos
drums and xylophone
[Music]
ice music is not just classical music or
experimental music it's a wide variety
of different things
this winter we'll put on about 45
concerts the concert hall has a specific
design it's one giant ice cave the igloo
right now is ten degrees Fahrenheit it's
definitely an issue in ice music that
people's fingers get cold people play
with a variety of different kinds of
gloves
some people play barehanded but for me
the temperature is you know the thing
that I really need to make ice music
work so many people just cannot wrap
their brain around a piece of ice making
a sound or a beautiful sound when they
come into the ice concert hall and
they're just very very pleasantly
surprised and that releases a real kind
of a high for people and then wow it's
it's amazing
[Music]